listen i'm the first one to hate on
myself like you cannot tell me anything
that i haven't already told myself
however
when you are saying something about me
that is
blatantly not true
that drives me mad jojo siwa is calling
out twitter trolls for criticizing her
as a judge on so you think you can dance
earlier this month after news broke that
matthew morrison was leaving the current
season of the show a twitter user wrote
in part quote dammit i saw the headline
judge leaves so you think you can dance
and got all excited yes jojo siwa was
out but nope it was matthew morrison
dammit jojo responded to the tweet
writing quote literally why tweet this
she then claps back with a breakdown of
her resume as a reminder to the
naysayers i don't
like to fight fire with fire or to fight
hate with hate but
i think a lot of people know me as that
beau girl that girl who goes like this
on a doll they don't know me from my
whole entire life i mean i started on a
dance tv show then i went to another
dance tv show then i had a billion
little dance guest star rolls danced on
a billion little news shows little
interview shows everyone would have me
dance i grew up in a dance studio
literally from the time i was two i did
my first solo then i went to beyond
dancing with the stars now i'm a judge
on so you think you can dance i could
tell you about every dance style i could
tell you moves in everyday so i like a
choreography with dance in every dance
style am i the smartest dancer in the
world by no means am i the most
knowledgeable in the whole world by no
means
but am i smart enough to be a judge on
so you think you can dance absolutely
and i
i don't like being that person that's
like i am good at this but if i had to
put a list of things down of things i
know the most about dance would be
number one on that list and if you know
me you know how much i know about dance
and when people are saying that that i
that i'm not i'm not knowledgeable
enough to be a judge i'm just like you
just don't know and you just sound silly
well while the haters hate jojo is
getting her coins easy is with the 19
year old outside dodger stadium as she
prepares to be a dodgers employee for
the day in her new facebook watch donkey
series jojo goes the actress is joined
by her celeb friends as she dives into
the fun she's always wanted to
experience i'm literally gonna be
working in the stadium getting the
stands ready getting the field ready
getting the concessions ready all the
things i also am excited to sell things
to people i think that's gonna be really
fun i'm just excited i love all things
having to do with baseball jojo also
teases her dream gigs viewers can expect
to see her take on in the series and
more first for the star
i will tell you that it is like all my
dream jobs that i've always wanted so
without telling you exactly what i'm
doing you know i've always wanted a
daycare
i've always wanted to work in a hospital
and be a doctor
i've always wanted to you know work on
something having to do with baseball
it's a lot of little fun adventures i
get to experience my first pride on this
show which is really fun and i get to be
in the weho pride parade and i have my
own flow and we got to design it that's
one of my favorite moments i wasn't
expecting that adventure like it was i
had a vision of what it would be but
then it was just beyond that and when it
comes to the guests we can expect the
actress is bringing the people closest
to her okay i'll tell you this my
three best friends
come on adventures with me my girlfriend
comes on adventures with me and there's
a couple of other people that i'm not
gonna spoil yet so but my three best
friends i'll tell you jenna who i was
partners with on dancing with stars ezra
who everybody on the internet knows my
best friend rachel ballinger who's a
youtuber which is one of my best friends
and then my girlfriend kai she's come on
a couple we got some olympians in there
there's they're really cool people well
it looks like jojo looks out for her
people she also reveals an a-lister
who's on her must-have list who is none
other than lady gaga
i'm not i'm not a club type of person
but i feel like if lady gaga took me i
feel like it'd be really fun just for
like one night well that one night of
fun is something jojo deserves the
influencer is booked and busy and admits
she's still learning how to balance her
career with her personal life it's
interesting i've learned that like
my life just is my life and
does it come with breaks not necessarily
but i have to like kind of carve out
breaks my life's like a pumpkin
and i just keep carving at it but it's
fun and i wouldn't trade it for anything
i've gotten to have a nice little beach
vacation just this week which has been
really nice everything that i do is
really fun and so i just had to make the
most of every day and just live life
jojo has managed to fit a lot of fun
experiences into her 19 years of life
including being a judge on so you think
you can dance season 17 is jojo's first
time in the judges chair and she's
loving it oh my god so you think has
been so much fun it's been a blast it it
really is just a cool
show to be a part of because it is so
iconic the dancers are just incredible
the top 12 is
so amazing and also just such nice kids
you know i've only known them for a
couple of days and they're all my age so
i shouldn't really call them kids but
they are all such good humans and it's
just really fun to get to be around them
[Music]